Teams playing in the World Cup...
...are vying for fame, glory, and the thrill of victory.
Aside from all that stuff, the champion team also gets a trophy like this.
It's one of the most coveted prizes in the world, and it's made here,...
...in a humble building on the outskirts of the Italian city of Milan.
That's the headquarters of GDE Bertoni,...
...a small family firm that's been crafting the trophies for 50 years.
The FIFA World Cup trophy depicts two figures holding the world...
...or is that a ball aloft?
It was designed by Bertoni's artistic director,...
...a sculptor named Sylvio Gazzaniga, back in 1971.
The 14-inch tall, 18-karat gold prize has the winning country engraved in its base.
France is the most recent name.
On December 18th, the world will watch...
...to see who will be the next name added to the trophy.
Oh, and the winners don't actually get the original trophy.
They have to settle for a gold-plated bronze replica that Bertoni's craftspeople prepare.